I think what we're going to do here is I
went on social media and I sort of uh
you know surveyed my audience and asked
them about red flags in
dating um I kind of did it two ways so
on Twitter I said what was the worst red
flag you've seen when when first dating
a woman and I separated it and I also
asked uh Ladies as well to see what they
would say um so we'll kind of do it from
both perspectives and uh also got a
bunch of replies off the YouTube
Community so we'll just we'll just hop
straight into this yeah so tells a story
about almost having sex with some guy I
responded that sounds like sex not
almost well he was wearing a condom so I
don't count that true story I ghosted
imagine saying that early on uh when
first dating like in the first first few
dates so that would fall into uh red
flag number 11 big Notch counts for sure
yeah I mean look you want you want a
friend Friends with Benefits you want uh
something shortterm you want something
late and easy nothing serious keep them
at arms length I mean look other dudes
have have indulged if you want to
whatever H you know have at her it's not
it's not like it's GNA make a difference
if it's you know 31 or
32 uh Kirby here says she hated her own
country to the point of being self
xenophobic it was bizarre I was done by
the end of the date at the end of the
date we were outside mine I went inside
and took off my clothes and started what
at the end of the date we were outside
my place I went inside took off my
clothes and started playing Pokemon she
stood there surprised and I said bye so
she left my revenge or me being petty I
guess that's kind of petty um sounds a
little dorky I would not take it there
but she's hating her own people in
country that's a little bit weird man
like like that's like the whole
self-deprecating it's like when guys
sort of like you know self
self-deprecate and they sort of insult
themselves Danny here says um asking for
presence and you to pay for everything
immed immediately that's just brat
behavior
um look if she's young innocent pure
virgin you know you're looking for wife
stock uh you know you're going down
these sort of conversations and routes
then maybe that has some value but um
you know for the average Western woman
today it's like pound sand you know yeah
women are only worth your time and
investment and Financial Resources when
they prove that they're worth something
and they're not going to prove that
they're worth something until you deal
with them over several weeks several
months right so you can see what they're
made of so you can get a feeling for
them right so early on first date second
date you know you need to pay for
everything I need gifts and
presents bye Ray here says uh the
communication was inconsistent and the
interest shown was
fluctuating uh they would Express I'm
assuming he means she would Express guys
be precise in your language The Four
Agreements be impeccable with your word
okay I'm going to keep harping on this
because it keeps happening people using
words like partner instead of boyfriend
or girlfriend or you know they would
Express or I want to date somebody no if
you're a man you're straight you're
dating a chick they there's no pronouns
there's no they them or any of that
use correct
language she would Express a desire to
become closer only and then push away
she would then vanish taking an in
ordered amount of time to respond before
reeing sorry before re reappearing with
a peculiar excuse for the absence she's
a hoe she's like look women are never
really single okay like they're always
talking to some guy they're always
involved with some guy even on dating
apps if they're like hey I'm single I'm
looking for something serious I guar I
mean she's she's dating other guys like
she's talking to other guys she may have
been on several dates with other guys
she might have been with another guy and
spent the night at his place the other
night and woke up in the morning and
went home and is now talking to you it
it's not that uncommon right so if her
interest and she's distant and she's not
communicating with you if you message
there's hours that go by before she
responds if a woman has genuine burning
desire for you she will respond
immediately there's no oh you know I was
busy for the last you know 36 hours
because my cat sprained its eye looking
at a disco ball and I had to go to the
veterinarian and pay all this money to
fix it and it was very devastating shut
the f no forget about it no no no Adam
here says daddy issues drinking
argumentative oh man it's your entire
list and and some yeah so again if you
guys don't have the entire list go to
the uh email list opt in and get it all
uh the daddy issues is effing massive
though it's an immediate gotta go look
I'm I'm gonna coign this very very
strongly you know it it's I put it
number one on my list daddy ISU is
number one on my list for Red Flags uh I
dated a gal for several years that uh
had a incredibly poor opinion and
relationship with her father it went
from an incredibly good relationship
with her father the way that she
described it to incredibly poor uh
citing indiscretions and abuse and all
these other stories and it's like it
just didn't add up it just did not add
up that you know she went from daddy's
little girl with a good relationship
they had fun they respected each other
to he doesn't even exist right
um if a chick doesn't have a good
relationship with her old man and he's
around and you know he's a good man and
he's good at being a man um the problem
isn't probably with him you know for
being honest on a balance of
probabilities more often than not it's
going to be her so look ignore it if you
want invite her into your life date her
marry her if you want I don't care you
know uh I'm not the penis police do
whatever the hell you want with your
life but I'm telling you women with
daddy issues are a freaking nightmare if
they don't respect their father they're
not going to have a high opinion of men
you're a dude she's not going to have a
high opinion of you she's going to
dismiss you she's going to utilize you
you're just an accessory you know situ
situations like that uh it's also
closely very very highly correlated um
with border life personality disorder um
I don't know what the exact numbers are
today the last time I saw a stat it was
something like one in five or one in
Four Women uh are either diagnosed or
undiagnosed with the condition and
they're they're hot they're cold they're
warm they're loving they're you know
they're frigid they whatever it's look
find out for yourself I know a lot of
guys are going to be like yeah okay Rich
that's fine I'm just going to figure it
out for myself when you see it you'll
see it and you'll come back to this and
be like he was right go on Amazon and
write a review and say You Know Rich was
right about this sort of stuff uh daddy
issues uh here's one Carter said chick
had a calendar with get ass eaten
written on it for
Saturday she's a hoe big Notch count
number 11 red flag number 11 I
mean have fun again indulge 50 other
guys probably have make sure you wrap it
up protect yourself all that sort of
stuff but uh do not make her a
girlfriend do not invite her into your
life as a wife as a mother of your kids
uh Sho that's it um she drank more than
I did and I wasn't holding back
alcoholic women
um red flag number 20 addictions right A
lot of these are already on my list
right uh Jonathan like look guys if you
deal with a chick and she's addict to
drugs and alcohol or shopping or
shopping and returning things um TV show
like uh Bachelor Bachelorette drama
stuff like that uh that's all that's
going on in her world like she's got
addictions to unhealthy cigarettes you
know um you're you're GNA have problems
with her you know she she can't regulate
her behavior she can't re she she
doesn't have the ability to say no to
things right it's the whole um
marshmallow test that I've talked about
before you know you delay gratification
you want to deal with a woman that has
the ability to say to say no to things
and preserve um you know her
relationship with certain vices you know
for example look everybody likes sugar I
like sugar I I like donuts I'm on the
worst diet right now for the
next I have five more days I'm on this
crazy diet I'll explain it in a totally
separate video all I'm all I'm basically
eating is
turkey sorry ground turkey uh um
cauliflower rice uh Butternut Squatch
and apple uh soup that's it right it's
working and I'll explain why it's
working shortly but it's it's it's
brutal but you drive by the doughnut
shop and you're like oh I could really
do with a freaking you know honey crer a
Boston cream sort of thing right like
you like you have the draw to these
vices and you have to have the ability
to say no and and and and basically
Bally tell these things to off in
your life right um if a woman can't do
that she's probably shared her body with
a lot of dudes she's probably got some
addictions to certain things and it
doesn't matter if it's alcohol or if
it's shopping and shopping and returning
things it doesn't matter what it happens
to be you don't want to deal with that
on a long-term basis you can it's not
that you can't it's just that your life
will become more uncomfortable more
difficult more combative uh it's going
to annoy you okay trust me when I say
this I'm I am not a spring chicken I've
done all of these things and I'm
speaking from wisdom wisdom comes from
making stupid mistakes this is why you
know we have these conversations I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out